excellent effort of T that one had a almost
went on five hole on markstrom then the quick
backand from a short angle as dry Sidle took
one to the face but there's Ryan nen Hopkins
winning that little puck battle getting
it across to Kane but markstrom shutting
the door markstrom sharp in the early Point
as he has beener his losing streak there's
a back in side of the net and it'll be
kolak moving the puck rebounds SCS kolak
moved in and an Edmonton area kid has the
opening goal up the Tim Horton's Heritage
Classic well the crowd Roar of 60,000 a little
different than 18,000 indoors and you know
following up a couple of good shifts by the top
line just getting the puck to the net with a good
traffic in front inside position you had both Kane
and Heyman but as you mentioned coming back from
the point he kind of gets lost kulak rotated
around gets in on the backand markstrom made
the first save couldn't find the rebound and
kulak with the backhand makes it one nothing
first of the year for Brett kulak a former cow
flame as well and the ice breaker goes to the
home side well one of the troubles this season
early on is five on five goals against and here's
just defensively not in a position to box out and
nice smart read though by kulak coming in from the
point and and so often that happens where you get
two of the forwards in with the defense in front
of the net and the forward on the other side for
Ryan Huska doesn't pick up the defender coming in